>> Well, thank you very much everybody for
being here.
I don't think our special guest today needs
much of an introduction.
But I hope most of you, all of you know, Cherie
Blair.
Cherie's a barrister and a part-time judge
whose focus is public law
and human rights.
She practices in many UK courts as well as
the European Court of
Justice.
Mother of four.
Very passionate about women's rights issues,
women's inequality,
religious freedom.
A whole bunch of other stuff.
And also is the wife of our prior Prime Minister
for ten years -- Prime
Minister for ten years, not wife for ten years.
CHERIE BLAIR: No, wife 29 years on Sunday.
>> 29 on Sunday.
CHERIE BLAIR: This last Sunday. We just had
our 29th anniversary.
>> Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
CHERIE BLAIR: How many years have you been
married?
>>18.
CHERIE BLAIR: 18. Not bad.
>> That's not bad.
I'll never catch up though.
You'll always be 20 years ahead.
CHERIE BLAIR: That's just cause I'm older
than you.
Not perhaps as much as --
[LAUGHTER]
>> We won't go there.
She also has a First Class degree of London
School of Economics, which I found very fascinating.
But more importantly, she's recently written
a book called Speaking for
Myself, which was published in May 2008.
And the paperback version comes out soon.
CHERIE BLAIR: In June.
>> In June.
And a Chinese version comes out --
CHERIE BLAIR: Also in the summer.
>> Fantastic.
Wonderful.
And has been on the bestseller list many different
places, I noticed.
So I was telling Cherie earlier, I've read
17 -- I've never done this
before.
CHERIE BLAIR: Haven't you?
>> You've done this at least -- I saw four
videos on YouTube, where
you've done it.
So at least you've done it four times.
I know you've done it a lot more times.
So we're going to talk about the book we're
going to talk about issues
that Cherie is passionate about.
And she's promised to talk about technology
because she's a
self-proclaimed geek, so she says.
So why don't we start with your book, if that's
good.
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, actually, funny enough,
When I came in here, I didn't know I was going
to be talking about the
book on a beach.
And I see all of you certainly as though you're
on a beach.
I'm, on the other hand, seem to be in a bit
more in the sort of more
business --
>> I think that we would be a lot more comfortable
for us to use.
CHERIE BLAIR: Funny enough, the book -- I
wanted to write a book which
actually you might like to read on a beach.
There was a lot of publicity at the time about
my book and what it was
going to be about.
And it was going to be some sort of political
diatribe.
That was never what I wanted to do.
And that's not what the book's about.
It's actually a woman's book.
It's a story of a woman who's in her 50s.
Who in a 50-year journey has come on a journey
which isn't unique.
Though in the end, she ended up at 10 Downing
Street, which is
obviously more unusual than many others.
But the journey that I made over those 50
years reflects a journey that
so many women have made in the developed world
over the 50 years.
And I talk a little bit about my mother and
my grandmother both of whom
who left school at 14.
Both of whom who were intelligent women who
had a lot to offer but
didn't get the opportunities that I was offered.
And both of whom who were absolutely determined
that I should be able,
and my sister should be able, to take advantage
of those opportunities.
And I'm very conscious that that's not an
untypical story, though it
has atypical elements.
And that's what I wanted to tell.
And I wanted to see that if a girl like me
coming from working class
Liverpool can get to the White House and to
meet the Pope, and all the
other things I've done --
That any girl or any boy actually, given the
right education and the
right opportunities, can go wherever they
want to go.
>> So another book describes a journey.
And a lot of people here in this room, some
of the best and brightest,
are in the early stages of their journey of
life.
What can you give as advice to all these people
in terms of what are
some of the things that they should remember
as they undertake this
journey which you can draw upon from your
book or your life?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I think first off, never
be too planned.
I think you always need to make allowances
for the unexpected.
I'm a great believer in seizing opportunities
as they along and also trying things.
Now, that's got me into trouble, by the way.
Because sometimes having an open mind and
trying to try things can get you into trouble.
But on the other hand, the curiosity about
the world, and what it has
to offer, I think, is something is that gets
me up every morning even
now.
>> What else would you say to these people
aspiring to --
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, these people, of course,
you were telling me
there're all already high achievers.
They've already had opportunities which other
people can only dream of.
And the reason they're here, I think, is because
they actually want to
think of ways to make the sort of opportunities
they've had available
to everyone else.
Which is why I said to you I'd love to talk
about technology.
Because I think technology is really a key
to what we can deliver in
the 21st Century, which you could've only
dreamed about in centuries
beforehand.
That's not to say that there are some disadvantages
with technology but
it's also a huge opportunity.
>> So let's go to technology and we'll come
back -- we'll keep going
back and forth depending on what you want
to talk about.
You've Googled yourself, I presume?
[LAUGHTER]
We all have.
It's okay.
We're amongst friends.
CHERIE BLAIR: No, no.
Of course I've Googled myself but it's a little
bit sort of uninformative, really, because
all you get, you get the
whole of the stuff from the Daily Mail, you
know, frankly.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't want to go there.
And certainly not if you're me, do you want
to go there.
And so, yes, of course.
I use Google all the time to find things.
But also, of course, conscious that sometimes
you find things on Google
that aren't true not at least if you read
the Daily Mail.
>> That's true.
Well, you know, we just try and help people
find information.
We can't validate the information.
CHERIE BLAIR: You can't validate the information.
>> We were talking earlier upstairs about
Facebook --
CHERIE BLAIR: Yep.
>> And you said that's a bit of dangerous
place for you to go, given
how many people would be interested to finding
out what you do and
where you are.
But your kids are on Facebook?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, my kids are on Facebook
but from time to time
they've had to come off Facebook.
Because the problem that they've found is
that -- they get put --
You go into Facebook, and it's like it's your
environment.
And that's certainly what they think.
But the truth is it's also an environment
that the press can get into.
And so there have times when we then find
that pictures that my
daughter may have put onto Facebook have then
been taken by the papers
and published.
And what she might have wanted to share with
her community in Facebook
particularly in an era what she thought she
was in a private space, she
doesn't actually want published to her parents,
frankly.
Not the least to the Daily Mail.
And so, it is a problem, I think, that if
you're involved in public
life or if you're a child of someone involved
in public life -- even
when you're a private person yourself -- that
doesn't mean that other
people don't think that you're a non-private
person.
>> But do you think that things can stay private
on the Internet at
all?
Some of the kids who are there on Facebook
could end up in public life
five years from now.
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I think, it's strange,
isn't it? Because I think
that people when you use Facebook, when you
use the Internet, do think
it's private.
I think.
I mean, they may be wrong about that.
But that's what kind of makes it you're having
a conversation, you're
relaxed.
And yes, you think you're sharing it with
your -- whoever it is.
You were talking about communities self-selecting
so you think you're
sharing it with a community of like-minded
people.
But, of course, there's always the opportunity
for you to be sharing it
with people actually you don't want to be
sharing it with.
So that's one the challenges of technology
as well as one of the
opportunities.
It brings all sort of different people together,
but it also raises
issues about what are the consequences of
that.
It's not least me talking about me putting
up a POSIEDON,
again, wanting to do that.
But being very conscious, of course, because
I want to have -- I want
to help women get in contact with other women.
I always remember I was doing a speech in
Russia, and I often do Power
Point presentations of my speeches.
And I wanted some pictures of Russian women.
So I went into Google and I put in "Russian
women."
[LAUGHTER]
And at the time I was -- at the time, I was
still in Number 10.
And suddenly these, I thought, this is not
what I was thinking.
This is not the sort of Russian women I was
thinking of.
And I also thought at any moment now the Downing
Street sort of --
>> Security people.
CHERIE BLAIR: Security people are going to
come rushing in here and
seize the computer, and have me disciplined
for bad behavior.
Obviously, you have to be pretty careful,
don't you?
>> So I was having the same conversation with
somebody who has a
17-year old about being on Facebook.
And he was try to go tell her daughter that
be careful whatever you put
up there could show up in the public life
at some point in time.
And she took her dad for the a walk and explained
that, Dad, this is a
generational gap thing.
That mostly likely the person who is going
be interviewing me is also going to be on
Facebook.
So what do you think, just old people like
you and me who are worried
about this information and the new generation
really is going to be
different?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I think it goes back to
what I said.
I think that they're perfectly happy.
Because she'd be perfectly happy for the person
who is interviewing her
is presumably her age, and is someone -- because
they're in that
community.
But would she be so happy --
I know your daughter is a bit young for this
yet --
but would this 17-year old girl be so happy
if in fact what
they were saying on Facebook was actually
on her father's newspaper the
next day with banner headlines saying, you
know, business executive's
daughter or whatever.
And that, that's the question.
>> That's probably not a good idea.
CHERIE BLAIR: So I don't think that's about
old and young.
I think it's about not always appreciating
the pitfalls.
>> So you talked about, you know, your kids
having to be taken off
Facebook and your being on Facebook not being
a good idea.
CHERIE BLAIR: No, no. You're persuading me
that I should --
YouTube, maybe.
>> I think YouTube.
I think you should definitely have a channel
on YouTube.
What do you guys think?
I think she needs to have a channel on YouTube.
We'll talk about that after.
CHERIE BLAIR: As I told you, I'm always liking
to try things.
And it's always getting me into trouble.
So when I get into trouble, I'm going to call
you and blame you.
>> We're trying to find her a camera slightly
smaller than that that
she can take with her when she goes -- so
we'll get you on a YouTube
channel.
But you touched upon something which is the
notion of public life,
and having your kids having to grow up in
the media spotlight.
And pretty much you having spent a lot of
your life now in the media
spotlight.
How does that impact life and how is that
different?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I think one of the things
I wanted to do again in
the book was to try and give -- my husband's
going to write --
he's writing a book and it will come out soon
and in fact will be all about
the politics --
>> Which one is going to be better?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, it depends what you're
looking for.
I mean, he's not going to talk about some
of the things that I talked
about.
And indeed when he read the book I think he
skipped over quite a few
of the things overwhelmed with embarrassment.
But I wanted to try and convey something about
what it is like to live
or to try and live a private life in very
public circumstances.
And yet in some ways, it's a bit of the story
of my life.
Because when I was a girl, my father was very
famous for his time.
He was an actor and he was very fortunate
that he became the sort of
young interest in what was one of the very
first comedy soap operas in
Britain in 1960s called "Till Death Do Us
Part."
And my father literally played himself, really,
was the SCASGET
scarsgot son-in-law of Warren Mitchell who
was the working class
racist, East End, opinionated person in the
family.
And this was very much cutting edge at the
time.
And so I suddenly found myself at school being
the child of somebody
very famous.
Then of course I ended up married to somebody
And I still think as I said before, look,
one day I'll probably be the
mother of somebody very, very famous.
And so it's an interesting question about
how public life and private
life coincide.
And when we went into Number 10, my first
priority was to ensure that
my kids, whatever else I did, was that I preserved
a private space for
my children.
And a lot of the time we were in Number 10,
it was quite a struggle to
try and make that happen.
Because the other thing I wanted to do --
and because my father was famous, but my father
abandoned my mother and my sister and I with
his mother in Liverpool and went off to pursue
his career in London.
So though he was famous, he wasn't at home.
And so I was always at one stake removed.
I was also very concerned that my children
should feel that whatever
happened when we were in Number 10 wasn't
something that was being
imposed on them that they were very much a
part of it.
And it was a bit of tension there, really,
between making sure that
your family is involved and feel involved.
And at the same time protecting them from
the press who say, well, if
you allow your child to be photographed at
all, it means that we can
then follow them around and do anything we
like.
Now, as a lawyer, I happen to know that that's
not how privacy law
works.
But sometimes there's obviously always a constant
tension between the
press who always want more, and the personal
who always wants to
preserve a private space.
>> What do you think about the UK media?
CHERIE BLAIR: Oh, I love them.
>> We are on camera, so.
CHERIE BLAIR: What you have to understand
is that, you know, a free
media is a really, really important part of
democracy.
I totally and utterly accept that.
But I think there's a difference between the
public interest as we
would define it --
which is things that the public are legitimately
interested and entitled to know about --
and things that the public might be interested
in which may, of course, and in fact we know,
of course, is often stuff which is more about
gossip and celebrity and lifestyle.
Which wouldn't necessarily be embraced by
the noble cause of ensuring
democracy functions well.
But because you have a challenging and connected
media.
>> So let's go back and try to bridge media
and technology.
Because all of us here constantly face this
conversation with media
given that things are more on the Internet,
and there's a lot of
conversation about newspapers being in trouble?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, it's true.
And you know, as a politician, you have to
engage with the media.
Because democracy is all about the people
holding their elected
officials accountable.
And therefore, they need to know what their
elected officials are
doing.
And the elected officials who have a program
for government, also want
to actually explain what's going on.
And that's why the media is very, very important.
On the other hand, if it gets hijacked into
trivia which is why the
problem that I sometimes encountered, you
know.
When you government had a serious issue, if
all that was being talked
about was Cherie's latest gaffe, then actually
I was damaging something
that I cared very deeply about which was that
the New Labor Government would be a success
and would deliver.
And so you know so you're constantly in danger
of being sidetracked in
your mission.
Now, the newspapers.
Are we going to need newspapers?
I'm sure we're going to need -- we were just
talking before, you have
all this information on the Internet.
And you do need some sort of way of filtering
that information.
And that's basically what journalists have
done through the centuries
is help filter the information.
So content, journalistic content, I think
is very important.
How it's delivered on the other hand, it's
like a different question,
isn't it?
Because though I still get my newspaper and
like to read it,
particularly when I'm traveling, actually,
I will probably go on to the
Internet and get that information.
I know my kids, of course, get so much of
their information through the
new media.
And that's -- that's definitely a generational
thing.
And a real challenge for the more traditional
media.
>> So shifting to another Google service,
you mentioned that you've
looked up your house on Google Street, have
you not?
CHERIE BLAIR: I have indeed.
>> But one of your houses is not on Google
Earth and the other one is?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, we have a little place
in the country.
And that's kind of, I think because it's in
the country, you know.
As far as I gather, your coverage doesn't
cover everything yet.
But obviously our house in London is very
much on the Google.
It's very, actually, I was looking for something
--
>> It's a nice, sunny, bright day when they're
taking the picture.
CHERIE BLAIR: Yes, it's a rather nice -- it's
a rather nice picture.
You go on to the Google Maps, you get your
directions, and then you now
click on that little button, and you actually
--
>> Fantastic.
CHERIE BLAIR: I was fascinated.
>> One of the things we talked about was this
balance that one has to
strike between the role of technology and
privacy for an individual.
Since you're a lawyer you talk about human
rights and you talk about
these things.
How do you think we strike that balance right?
And what should we be thinking about?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, you know, I think that
there's never a hundred
percent right answer about this.
And the more you talk about human rights you
have to understand, it's
always about balance.
There are very few absolutes in human rights.
In fact, even the right to life for a long
time was qualified by
capital punishment.
Now in Europe now we don't do that qualification
anymore.
And you can't be a member of the Counsel of
Europe if you have the
death penalty.
But the fact was even that most fundamental
right to life did have a
proviso.
Also torture and slavery are some of the absolute
rights.
But when you start talk about privacy, the
right to family life, when
you talk about the rights of association,
free speech --
all of them come with the requirement that
you can only do that so long as you don't
interfere with the rights and freedoms of
others.
And all of them actually come with this notion
of responsibility.
And you know you can't -- human rights are
much more nuanced than that.
And then of course, there isn't a hierarchy
of rights.
So your right to disseminate information comes
up against my right to
privacy.
And that's about trying to strike a balance.
And generally speaking, the rule is what you
do is you do the least
intrusive way of restricting freedom.
Which is commensurate with giving rights and
freedoms to others.
And is that involves government's trying to
strike a balance.
It involves individuals and companies trying
to strike a balance.
And in the end, if the balance, if they can't
agree on where the
balance is, it involves the courts adjudicating
as to where the balance
should be struck.
The advantage, I would say this as a lawyer,
about having it decided in
the courts is that you do in the court, of
course, have a debate and
the two sides of the argument are put.
And in the end, the judge has to reach a conclusion
and when he reaches
that conclusion, he gives you his --
Why do I say he?
She gives you her reasons.
And so you have a reasoned judgment, and if
you don't like it you can
then appeal.
So as someone who believes in the rule of
law I think that's a good
structure for trying to reach this balance.
But everybody has a part to play.
>> We were talking earlier about DNA information,
for example.
And how if we had access to a lot of DNA information
from around the
world there's a possibility you could do a
lot to help?
CHERIE BLAIR: It's definitely, very much so.
>> And the risk now if you collect everybody's
DNA information that
intrusion of the people's privacy --
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, actually, I think that
if it was happening to
everybody, if everybody had their DNA collected,
then everybody would
then be in the same boat.
I think the concern has been, and of course
there's been a recent case
about that, because that it wasn't happening
to everybody but it was
only happening to certain people.
And they were people who were in a bit, one
way or another, come into
connection with the police.
And it was agreed, and doing this balancing
act that if someone is
actually committed in a crime and has been
convicted, then clearly that
is right that their DNA should be collected
and kept.
The question is, however, if they are not
charged with a crime or if they're acquitted
then what happens?
And the Europe Court has decided that across
Europe there are
restrictions on that.
And had an unrestricted access, and they decided
that they felt that
that wasn't the right balance.
But actually, I mean I think there could be
a case for everybody
contributing their DNA because we do know
that the bigger the --
You know, we had a bigger DNA database than
many other places in Europe
and because of that, we have been able to
identify people who have
committed serious crimes.
And it doesn't seem like a day doesn't go
past or certainly a week
doesn't go past when some DNA evidence has
either solved the crime
today,
or as we saw just recently has proved somebody
innocent years after the
event.
So DNA is a very important tool.
But it has to be the way you use that tool
has to be done so that there
are checks and balances.
And so there's a balance between people's
rights and the rights of the
community to protect itself.
And you know this is a debate that is absolutely
right that we should
have.
>> This is a good thing we're taking pictures
of everybody's house,
almost everybody.
So we're doing it to everybody is the same
way, like --
CHERIE BLAIR: You know in some ways if everybody's
in the same boat
then you can see that that's a good argument.
I also because I sit as a judge and I see
in cases in court,
we have quite often we have camera evidence,
video camera evidence, and it seems to get
better all the time.
And but -- often, of course, you find that
when it comes to the actual crucial moment
that's just the bit you can't see.
>> So let's change topics. You know you're
very passionate about
equality issues.
And we were talking about Kenya, Rwanda, and
other parts of the world.
Just give us a sense of all the things you
see in that area.
What do you think are important things?
You had a very interesting point about making
sure we are designing
technology which is of a gender neutral --
CHERIE BLAIR: Accessible to women, yes.
>> So I would love to hear your thoughts on
that.
CHERIE BLAIR: I mean basically it all comes
back to my life story.
You know, I was a girl brought up by two strong
women who didn't have
opportunities that I was given.
And you go across the world and you see so
many wasted opportunities
because in so many cultures and in so many
societies, women just aren't
valued in the same way as men.
And we still have a world today where a girl
baby is born in India or
in China -- or maybe not even born because
they know it's a girl baby
and so it's aborted simply because of that.
Or is born but then infanticide happens.
There are plenty of places around the world
where you have a baby, and
it's a boy and it's a cause for celebration.
And you have a baby and it's a girl, and it's,
you know, at best,
better luck next time.
As long as we start from that position where
women are not valued the
same as men, and we are not actually having
the world as it ought to be
where women and men are of equal worth and
of equal value and come
together and work as partners, which is much
more creative.
I can see here you've got men and women.
And the reality is it's much more creative
when we use our
complementary skills.
But, you know, it goes on.
You go to school.
Girls -- 70 percent of the illiterate children
in the world are girls.
Why is that?
Because when it comes to making choices about
which child you educate,
boys are more likely to be educated than girls.
And yet we know that if you do educate a girl
child you have, she's
more likely to have fewer children.
She's more likely to marry later.
She's more likely to make sure her children
are inoculated.
She's more likely to educate her own children.
So you couldn't have a better investment but
many, many countries,
we're failing there.
And then you go on, girls get married too
young.
Therefore they lose out on education.
Or the women here will know even if not in
this company,
we could talk about that, but even if it's
not in this company, in other companies they've
been, you know --
We find that girls leave university now probably
doing better at
university than men, that within three years
of women graduating they
already earn 15 percent less than the equivalent
male graduate.
Why is that?
We could talk about that.
And I could go on.
So I think the women's issues.
You know in the 21st Century, the 21st century
is not the century where
women become equally respected of equal value
with men then we will
have failed and that's my passion.
We need to make sure those opportunities are
there.
So then I think what can I do to do with that?
I've touched on education being a key.
But lots of things are going on about education
at the moment, really
good work.
But the thing that struck me about my own
story in comparison is that
it was the fact that I was able to be economically
independent, to get
and to keep any own money and make my own
choices about that, that made
a big difference.
And so I'm very interested in how we give
this economic independence to
women.
And what I want to try and do, is to help
women entrepreneurs, just
help them link up with other women and grow
their businesses.
Now by that I don't mean microfinance.
I'm sure everyone in this room knows microfinance
is a fantastic
success story.
Not designed originally for women.
Now very much about women.
But it's still about helping mothers educate,
it's still about keeping
women within the confines that society has
put to her.
It's very, very hard.
Not all of those women will be entrepreneurs,
but it's very hard for
those women who come up through microfinance
who are entrepreneurs to
gain access to the next stage of growing their
business.
So I'm concentrating on helping with training
programs and mentoring
and networking advice for that grade of women
who can then break out of
their homes and become drivers of development
in their country.
And for that, I'm sure there's a lot we can
do in reality.
>> Let's focus on Africa.
Because as you mentioned earlier, there's
a lot of stuff that Google is
doing in Africa and wants to do in Africa
on the infrastructure side.
And you've touched along upon Rwanda and the
situation there.
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I telling you -- would
you like me to tell the
story?
>>Yeah, please.
CHERIE BLAIR: In fact, I describe in the book.
Because I go to, and I went first with Laura
Bush, just after the
G8 Summit.
I've been fascinated about Rwanda for a long
time because, of course,
Rwanda had the genocide.
And it also had an international tribunal
that dealt with the crimes
against humanity there.
And as a lawyer, I was very interested in
how as a legal system do you
cope when society collapses to such an extent
that people who were
neighbors start doing the most unspeakably
horrible things to each
other.
So I went to Rwanda and then I went a second
time.
And my second time they took me up to a village
in the north of the
country which had been ravaged by the genocide
and been sort of left
for dead.
And an American entrepreneurs had come and
helped them set up a
cooperative.
And they were doing fair trade coffee.
And in fact, their coffee was being sold in
Sainsbury's here.
And the women were very much involved in that
project.
In particular, they trained the women to do
-- I didn't realize this
but, you know, like you do wine tasting?
You do the same thing with coffee beans.
In fact they tried -- I tried to do it but
I was hopeless because you
have to swill it around your mouth and spit
it out.
I couldn't get my head around it.
But these women were fantastic.
But they were some of the best testers and
graders of coffee.
And I was talking to them, and they were telling
me about how they were
using the Internet to contact their suppliers.
Because then they would know what the price
of coffee was going to be
and they could also deal with queries and
requests.
And they took me to their office where they
had a computer and they
were doing all this on Skype.
Here I am in the middle of nowhere in Rwanda,
and here they were
communicating with Sainsbury's in London and
people in America using
Skype.
And when they weren't using the computer for
their business, the women
made it available to the school in the village
so the kids could use it
for their projects.
And I thought, you know, isn't this amazing?
That could not have happened 10, 15 years
ago.
But it just shows the power of technology.
But one of the things I've subsequently learned,
however, is that
technology in Africa is becoming available
but it's very man-centered.
The people who were going in there when they
talk about, you know, you
can use this for banking.
You can use this for insurance.
You can use this for communicating with your
markets.
In their heads, they see a man doing all those
things.
And if you talk, if they talk about and think
about women using it at
all,
what they'll say is, oh well, for the women,
of course, it means
that they can speak to their mother or their
friends,
you know, more often during the day.
And so you, it's really important that if
we're talking about access to
technology in Africa, that we make it so that
it isn't gender centric.
That it isn't masculine.
That it's actually seen as something that's
available to women as well
as men.
Otherwise, we'll have the same problem that
you have about women
getting access to finance.
The same problem for women having access to
technology which is a
really important tool to develop your business.
>> So in that context, another thing which
is I think very common
amongst the people here, not only they're
all smart and they work for
Google, is all of them I think I speak for
all of them --
that they have a passion for trying to change
the world.
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, me too.
>> And the question is what advice can you
give them in terms of them
individually making a contribution towards
changing the world?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I absolutely think it
does start with the
individual.
I think there's lots of things we can do more
generally.
But in the end it's about you and your view
of the world and your
belief in yourself.
And the fact that you can make a difference.
And if we can teach our children, if we bring
everybody up to see that
actually each one of us can make a difference.
And we can do that in all sorts of ways even
in simple things like
buying the Rwandan coffee.
I've just been involved in a campaign about
trafficking women and
children across the world.
And Cadbury's have just announced that from
this summer their Cadbury's
Dairy Milk is going to be a fair trade product.
Because I don't know if you know, but actually,
there's a big problem
in West Africa
where a lot of the cocoa beans come from with
children and others being trafficked into
there.
Not for sex but as workers in collecting the
cocoa for which they don't
get paid.
They're just trapped there.
And there are now ways of ensuring that you
only buy cocoa beans from
places where that's not happening.
So taking decisions like that about your Easter
eggs that some of you
may be thinking of buying would be something
you can do.
But with the skills and knowledge in this
room, there is so much you
can do.
So much you can do nationally.
And I'm sure you probably have schemes already
where you link up with
schools and you do mentoring and help there.
And then, of course, internationally just
with what you're saying.
I know you're thinking about Africa at the
moment so think about some
of these things.
Think about the women in Africa as well as
the men.
Think about how much they have to offer.
>> So in that line, you know, you have all
this energy and all this
passion.
Where do you draw your inspiration from?
CHERIE BLAIR: From a number of things.
I think at the end, it does go back to my
mother and my grandmother.
And seeing them struggle when my father left,
my mother who had been --
she'd been accepted at RADA.
And so she'd gone to the Royal Academy of
Dramatic Art in the 50s and
then she'd -- she'd gone in her vacation.
She got the vacation job and that's how she
met my father.
He was the juvenile lead male, and she was
juvenile female lead.
And the next thing you know she's pregnant
with me.
And then several years on, her husband leaves
her, and she actually goes and works in a
fish and chips shop.
In the docks in Seaforth to --
It was the only job she could find where she
could be able to be there
for us during the day, and still work at night.
And you think the come down from thinking
you're going to be, you know,
a glamorous actress to working in a fish and
chips shop in the docks of
Liverpool.
And yet, she then, you know, pulled herself
up, got herself a better
job.
Educated two daughters, both of whom qualified
as lawyers, and ended up
as the mother-in-law of the Prime Minister.
She's had an incredible life.
>> So one of the things which we all struggle
with which we find as we
talk to people is since everybody's ambitious,
and really has
tremendous amounts of energy and passion in
this room,
we often struggle with striking the right
balance between work and life.
And you're a mother of four, you have a professional
career, you have a
very public life,
as well as you were married to an individual
who also has a very public life.
And how do you balance all these things so
that you can maintain your
relationships and -- keep the personal part
happy?
CHERIE BLAIR: I would say do as I say but
not necessarily as I do.
Because that's what I'm going to Malta tomorrow
to talk at a breakfast
meeting there with the wife of the Prime Minister
of Malta precisely
about these work/life issues.
And I wish I had the magic formula because
if I had, wouldn't I be a
wealthy woman?
But one thing I'm sure of is that this is
not just about women.
This is absolutely about men and women together.
And if we see this -- if we see work/life
balance issues as simply a
woman's issue,
we are completely missing the point.
Because if it's wrong to think of women as
simply only being able to
offer things within the confines of the home,
it's equally wrong to think the men actually
are only there to be the breadwinners and
that they don't care about their family life.
That they don't have a lot to offer.
It's very important, for example, that our
boys and our girls see
images of men, you know, of good men,
of active fathers who are contributing not
just in the work force but in their family
life.
And, of course, work/life balance isn't just
about bringing up
children.
It's about what you do about your elderly
parents.
Something that's becoming more of life issue
for me as --
and for many people.
And it's also about just doing the things
that you're passionate about.
I mean one of the problems I find is just
finding some time when
actually you're doing something for yourself.
And many of you in this room might sometimes
find that,
particularly some of you who are parents,
that you know by the time you've --
One young woman lawyer said to me that you
know if only my -- the
partners in this firm could understand the
amount, sheer amount of
effort that I've put into getting all my kids
out and everything sorted
out before I come into work,
they would never doubt the commitment that
I had to my work.
But in the midst of that sometimes you can
lose out on actually making
sure that you're still a person who's got
needs and rounded
experiences.
See, it's a really difficult question.
But it's not just about crushes at work.
That helps.
It's not just about making sure you have flexi-work.
And it's certainly in my tea company, I presume
it goes without saying.
I couldn't have done my career.
I couldn't have carried on as a lawyer if
it wasn't for the fact that I
was able to use the Internet and the intranet
from 10 Downing Street.
So I could actually carry on researching my
cases without having to
actually physically go into the office.
But it's not only about that.
It's also about an attitude of mind.
It's about accepting that people sometimes
may want to come into the
workforce.
So it may well be in your twenties you work
very, very hard.
But maybe in your sort of childbearing years,
you might want to take a
to work a bit more flexibly.
But if you do that, it's really important
that there's a way of getting
back into the workforce.
It's very important you keep connections,
that you keep your training
going.
And I myself when I was a young barrister,
in those days there wasn't
-- we didn't have a maternity policy,
and I thought at the time, I was so determined
at being the first woman in my chambers --
I was so determined to show that I could have
children, and still you
know, still be a good barrister.
And looking back on it now, I think that maybe
I thought I was changing
the system, and maybe I was just playing to
the system.
>> No doubt, yes.
CHERIE BLAIR: Because I wasn't -- there was
no concession made for the
fact you're pregnant.
And actually, we need to make some concessions.
Society needs to make concessions for the
fact of pregnant women need
to, you know, be essentially protected so
that their babies flourish.
I mean eventually, with my first son they
actually confined me to the
hospital bed.
You know, ten days before he was -- well,
actually, I think a month
before he was due because he wasn't growing
enough.
Now, in fact, it turned out afterwards that
all my babies were small, so actually it probably
was the right thing for me.
But it was kind of -- I was so busy doing
all these things and maybe I
wasn't looking after myself well enough.
You don't, you shouldn't put women in that
position.
>> So I want to ask people to think of questions
and ask questions
which are on their mind.
But before I do that, you can't come to Google
and not answer the
questions we ask every new Googlers.
So you're going to have to help me.
So should we start with the first concert?
CHERIE BLAIR: My first concert?
>> Yes.
CHERIE BLAIR: You mean that I performed in
or that I attended?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Both.
I know Tony used to sing in a band.
CHERIE BLAIR: Oh absolutely.
But I also -- in the 60s it was a big thing
about folk music.
And Joni Mitchell and Joan Baez.
I met Joan Baez recently.
I nearly died.
You know, I said, oh god, I used to sing your
songs.
I used to play a guitar and sing.
I thought well but probably very, very badly.
So that's for sure.
So that was the first --
>> Concert that you performed in.
CHERIE BLAIR: That I performed in.
And my first concert that I attended?
That's quite difficult.
I remember going quite early on to see Elton
John perform.
Later on, of course, he was at that first
time event at the White
House, and we had, we had with the Clintons.
And we had a State Visit.
And they put on a fantastic concert that Elton
John played in and
Stevie Wonder sang My Cherie Amour for me.
Pretty good.
One of the highlights.
>> What the other questions that we ask Googlers?
Before you -- go ahead Leanne.
What are the other Googlers questions?
First date?
CHERIE BLAIR: First date?
>> You want to answer that?
CHERIE BLAIR: Yeah.
Random fact.
Well, I'll do first date.
>> Do the first date.
I have already seen you talk about your boyfriends
in your interview
with the Dominic in the University of California.
So I think it's out in the public domain.
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, yes, it was more than
one.
I had -- surprisingly my husband doesn't like
to me to talk about it.
There were a few more boyfriends before him.
That's true.
But actually the -- the first date or the
first time I was kissed was
when I was about seven.
And --
>> Okay.
I don't think you're setting the right role
model here.
[LAUGHTER]
CHERIE BLAIR: With A boy whose, whose father
actually became --
Well, he has was the choirmaster at the school.
Because I was singing in the choir.
And it was under the -- in those days we still
had steam trains
traveling between Liverpool and Southport,
and that -- it was under one
of the bridges that went over the train.
And then my sister ran back and told my mom
about it.
Very embarrassing, cause years later having
told this story, the Daily
Mail, of course, go and tracked down this
ruddy chap.
No, no.
This very nice chap who now runs a pub in
-- somewhere in England.
And he was insisted that we were not seven
and that we were older than
that, but I am sure --
>> He insists he was legal age.
CHERIE BLAIR: No, no.
I think he insisted that we were about 9 or
10, but he was wrong.
>> Okay, well.
On that, do you have a question?
>> Yeah.
Well, it's cheeky because it's two questions.
Firstly, why did you join the Labor Party?
And secondly why didn't you ever stand for
Parliament?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I did stand for Parliament.
>> So I stand corrected.
CHERIE BLAIR: I joined the Labor Party because,
well partly, it's kind
of -- I came from a working class family,
and we always voted Labor.
And when I was --
When I was 16 they had a teacher at school
Mrs. Spate, who actually
cause I was at a convent school, but she was
a quaker.
And she was a member of the Labor Party,
and she invited me along to meetings.
And years later, she contacted me when I was
in Number 10.
And subsequent she's -- she died.
And you know, I still keep in contact with
her daughter who every year
sends me a little note.
So she was the first person who -- and I joined
the Labor Party because
I believe in social justice, in equality,
and its mission to make people like me have
the opportunities that I've been able to have.
If it hadn't had been for the Labor government
coming in this 1945 and
changing the system, you know,
a girl like me wouldn't have even got the
opportunity to go to school.
I was so fortunate because I had a full grant
to go to university.
Which was -- which was a fantastic opportunity.
You know, so I think I need to to give something
back.
And part of the way of giving something back
was to support the Labor
Party.
And I did stand for Parliament.
And in 1983, I stood in Thanet North, which
was a seat which is
basically around Margate and Herne Bay -- which
even in '97 didn't
become a Labor seat.
So it was never a surefire winner, that's
for sure.
But there was a brief period when Tony was
the candidate's spouse.
And this was not a happy period for him.
[LAUGHTER]
And I tell the story in the book of how just
in Easter, just before the
May election, or it was June, actually.
We'd been on holiday, and we came back from
holiday in France into
Dover.
We went to see my agent to talk about the
forthcoming election and so
we had lunch.
And at the end of lunch he said to Tony,
Tony would you mind but Cherie and I need
to talk a bit about the campaign and business,
so would you mind going out and helping my
wife wash up?
[LAUGHTER]
And so he went and helped his wife wash up.
And as he was drying the pots, she said, Tony
are you interested in politics at all or is
it just that you're doing this to support
Cherie?
I think that point he was about to divorce
me.
And I think what Hillary Clinton shows is
that it's not easy, actually, to be spouse
of a leader.
And I think she showed that she as a fantastic
First Lady.
And also had the potential to be a fantastic
President, and now
fantastic Secretary of State.
But I think Bill, possibly, who was a great
leader could have done with
a little bit more help about being a support,
you know, running that
First Lady role.
It's more difficult than you think.
>> I think you need to stand up.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> -- get your views specifically, on recent
calls about cutting
maternity leave from nine months to six months
to allow partners more
time off for that to be with their newborn.
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I actually think this
is a really interesting idea
and one which illustrates something I do feel
passionately about.
Which is, we should be talking about parenting
in the 21st Century.
And we should not be assuming that this is
all about women.
And in fact I think sometimes as women we
need to be careful.
You can often find that you go to the school
gate, you know, if you go
as a mother, that's fine.
You know, but a father going to the school
gate, you know,
and half the mothers are whether wondering
whether he's a child molester.
You know, we need to start being more comfortable
about the idea that,
you know, men too have a lot to offer in a
caring role.
And that's a challenge for women.
Because in a sense I suppose for a long time
we've been placed in this
area, and now it's about sharing this area.
Having -- having said that, I think I also
have said that we obviously
need to be do something to support a woman
when she goes through
essentially what is a physical process, pregnancy,
and you do need to
make allowances for that.
Because otherwise, you know, you can endanger
both the mother and the
child.
So there needs to be a balance there.
But shared parenting, shared responsibility
is the way ahead.
And actually I was very lucky.
The ironic thing is that if Tony and I had
both been barristers,
because he was doing more commercial law,
and I was doing more of the employment law,
which doesn't get paid as much.
If I'd fallen pregnant and he was still a
lawyer, it may well have been
that it would have been actually harder for
me to continue with my
work.
But the fact was that as I was fighting that
election in 1983, he went
off and got the Sedgefield seat which was
a safe seat.
And I discovered I didn't -- I thought I was
just in distress,
but it turned out that I was actually pregnant
with my first child at that point.
But because Tony then had become an MP, I
also found myself then being
the main breadwinner.
And so to that extent, there was a financial
incentive for me to carry
on working.
And Tony because he was an opposition MP,
and therefore wasn't in
government, had actually slightly more time
to be a hands-on father.
And he was -- you know, he always jokes and
unkindly shares with many
people that I'm, once I get to sleep at night,
you kind of have to
dynamite me out of bed.
And so often at nighttime, when the children
were crying it would be
Tony who would get up and then he'd bring
the baby to me.
And you know I would then feed, feed the baby.
And you know he was, he was definitely changing
nappies long before it
was fashionable.
Of course, it became more difficult when Leo
came along because he was
suddenly Prime Minister.
And you know I was wanting to persuade him
to take a paternity leave.
And of course Leo did very well because he
was actually born early on a
Friday at a week which actually was a Parliamentary
recess week.
And so there was no -- there was no question
time.
And so Tony was able --
He didn't take -- obviously he kept taking
phone calls.
And he worked on his boxes but he did base
himself up in the flat for
that week.
And the fact was as soon as Leo was born,
he wanted to be there.
As those of you who are fathers will know
that feeling, I'm sure.
And those of you who will become fathers will
experience it, too.
You want to be able to share in this new life
which the two of you have
created together.
That's really important.
[INAUDIBLE QUESTION]
[PAUSE]
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I think there's -- there
are two points there.
One is the issue of corruption, and what in
the speak we call
"governance issues."
And it's actually something that Tony feels
very passionately
about as well.
And in fact, he has, as part of his work that
he's doing now, a
charity.
And at the moment they're working both in
Rwanda and in Sierra Leone.
And their main purpose is trying to help with
setting up and supporting
a proper system of governance.
Which is particularly helping in both cases
to run the Office of the
President and Prime Minister
in the countries in a way which is transparent,
which is open, corruption-free, and efficient.
Efficient actually is really quite important,
as you can imagine.
I, myself, am interested in how we can use
the law to help with that.
Because in many of these countries like Rwanda,
for example, after the
genocides,
there were only about 15 laws in the entire
country.
I mean, that's a real challenge to try and
build up a legal system from
scratch.
And other thing I'm convinced of is that once
you get corruption in the
system, it's very, very damaging.
And it's, it's a very precious thing a corrupt-free
bureaucracy, a
corrupt-free judiciary.
And once you have that undermined, it takes
a long time to right.
So it's a really, it's a really important
issue.
And it's quite complicated and difficult subject
to tackle.
As for what we do about development, well,
I think one thing we've
certainly learned --
And if you listen to someone like Muhammad
Yunus, he will tell you this
as well, that handouts are not as good as
hand ups.
Imposing things on people without consulting
them doesn't work.
So if you're going to go in, what you must
do is you must consult the
local community.
You must make sure the local community have
a sense of ownership in it.
If possible, involve the local community in
the --
If you're talking about digging a well, or
laying a road, you know, so
that the jobs actually go to the local people.
It's also about even at a higher level, when
you're going in, lots of
countries have lots of consultants.
It's really important that the consultants
actually transfer the
knowledge, and leave it in the country.
Rather than having the knowledge, going in,
doing a project, and then
taking the knowledge out again.
So it's all about capacity building.
It's all about helping people, whether it's
a government or actually
individuals, help themselves because there's
a dignity in that.
And there's a learning experience in that
which, sometimes aid projects haven't always
encouraged.
[PAUSE]
>> Thanks. We touched on Street View earlier.
And as you know, some parties in this country
have reacted quite
strongly against Street View even going so
far as to ask for it to be
shut down.
And some have pointed out the irony that we
live in a country where the
public accepts, with little protest,
a government who collects vast amounts of
data.
Recently talking about tracking social networks
and e-mails and text
messages in the name of national security.
What are your views on that?
Should we be more worried about the government,
less worried freeing
information to the public?
CHERIE BLAIR: Well, I think it's what I said
before about the whole
question about privacy and rights to information.
It's about getting the balance right.
And, you know, when you have any of these
issues I think you have to
say well what -- what are we collecting this
information for?
Is it for a good purpose?
Cause if it isn't, then we shouldn't be doing
it anyway.
That's the first thing.
But let's assume therefore that there is a
legitimate purpose in that.
Are we then --
So the next question then is are we doing
in it the least intrusive
way?
And that may involve, for example, as I gather
you now do, allowing
people if they do object, to opt out.
Or it may involve actually saying you have
to have people opt in.
I mean, these are these are the questions
that need to be debated.
Lawyers love the concept of proportionality.
Is it proportional?
So it's that idea you don't use the sledge
hammer to crack a nut.
And actually, it's all about a scale and a
balance.
And it's about bringing the -- the balance
to the right tipping point.
And that may change over time.
And it's about debating.
It's about being transparent in what you're
doing.
And it's about making sure that you can justify
what you're doing as
actually benefitting people, cause if you
can't, then you shouldn't be
doing it.
>> We prefer the idea of opt out as opposed
to opt in, because it
becomes very onerous.
Hey, you know, I'm planning a building, you
have a choice to object as opposed to --
CHERIE BLAIR: But you would.
But there needs to be a discussion about whether
--
Because you have also a commercial imperative.
And so you know, is your commercial imperative
furthering on or not
furthering the public interest?
And the important thing is to debate that
and to debate you it
openly.
But I think the disadvantage is in somehow,
sometimes I don't like some
of the things that are in the press is this
kind of scare mongering
about things.
Because actually sharing information, having
information available is a
very powerful tool for good as well as for
bad.
And therefore we shouldn't, we shouldn't be
silly about this.
But we have to make sure that the proper checks
and balances is in
place.
>> Hi, you and I are both Catholics, I believe.
CHERIE BLAIR: Ah, yes.
>> How does it make you feel when you see
Cardinal Ratzinger or Pope
Benedict going to Africa, to many countries
which have double digit HIV
infection rates, telling people not to use
condoms.
And what do you think Catholics should actually
do about that?
CHERIE BLAIR: I think it makes me rather sad.
And I think that there is a real question,
and a real dividing line between contraception,
which I see as a way of preventing life beginning,
and abortion, which is about terminating a
life that has begun.
I think there is a distinction between the
two.
And that sometimes the condom issue doesn't
add clarity to that
distinction but rather makes it a lot more
muddy.
My own view is, and I've said this before,
that condoms are absolutely
essential in the fight against AIDS.
And that we should be encouraging people to
use them.
But, we also must understand that promiscuity
is a problem.
That actually sex is about relationships and
respect.
And that, that if you have a culture which
sees sex as just a
commodity, if we, that this is not necessarily
--
Well, this is not necessarily a bad thing,
it is a bad thing.
And therefore, how we encourage people to
behave responsibly,
and part of behaving responsibly to my mind
anyway
particularly in a country where there is an
endemic AIDS epidemic is to use safe sex methods.
But responsible sex is also really important.
And the idea that anything goes --
And the Pope, of course, was talking about
how promiscuity is a
problem.
And it is a problem, and he's right to draw
attention to that.
Again, we're talking about striking the right
balance, having a
discussion.
And making sure that we don't throw the sort
of dignity baby out with the bath water.
The dignity of individuals and the respect
there should be between a
man and a woman in all relationships including
sexual.
And actually for that matter, between same-sex
partners.
>> On that note, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]